[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today and
today's question comes from Warren in
Washington DC I have a large amount of
debt wouldn't it be better to file for
bankruptcy to have a fresh start and
then build wealth instead of taking
years to pay off debt and then start to
build wealth when is bankruptcy a good
option uh we would say in the very very
very rare case is bankruptcy an option
uh because most of the time it is a you
problem and bankruptcy doesn't solve a
you problem it may wipe debts away not
your student loans and then it's on your
record for a while uh but the problem is
usually when it comes to money it's us
it's the person handling it and so while
in one sense it could sound like an easy
um exchange I'll take bankruptcy for the
no debt it doesn't change the pattern of
what caused you to get in there in the
first place and and most time we find
people can get out of debt I mean rare I
don't I mean it's only been a handful
full of times on this show that you've
ever even uh entertained the idea of
giving someone advice for bankruptcy
yeah I I I don't tell people to file
bankruptcy and I don't tell people to
file
divorce um with the exception of uh a
situation where the wife is a punching
bag because her husband's scum in that
case file divorce get out of there he's
scum uh but other than that I don't tell
people to do the stuff like this I don't
make decisions like that for you on this
show I will tell you that you should
file bankruptcy about as often as you
should file for a divorce which is
almost never if you have a big fight
with your wife you don't go file for
divorce it's a we've been through a
rough patch this this summer you don't
go file for a divorce you work it out
you sit down with a marriage counselor
you sit down with your pastor you read a
marriage book or six um and you work on
it and you learn how to do it and you
fix it and the same thing's true with
your money now that's from a guy that
did file bankruptcy but we fought two
and a half
years to keep from filing bankruptcy
they were down to we've been sued 78
times before we filed bankruptcy they
were coming to take the furniture out of
our house and Rachel was 2 months
old and I decided they're not taking the
baby bed I fought this for two and a
half years I've sold everything we owned
I've done everything we could do took it
all the way to the bottom and then we
filed for bankruptcy in September of
1988 and uh that's what started this
whole ramsy Movement by the way was my
stupidity so uh and I fought it all the
way to the bottom I I now know things
that I didn't know then that I could
have done further there's some
techniques I could have used some dance
steps dance moves I could have used to
uh to delay it even further and I might
have made it through if I'm knowing what
I know now but um but I didn't know I
was out of gas and yours was all real
estate not beat out yeah it was all real
estate it wasn't
consumer I have any Consumer Debt hardly
at all um I borrowed on the cars to buy
houses so I didn't have car payments but
I had car payments but um so but anyway
all all that aside you're uh uh Warren
you're not
bankrupt you're bankruptcy is not a
technique for Building
Wealth it's like life insurance is not a
technique for building an
estate you don't buy life insurance to
leave your children something because
that doesn't work it leaves the
insurance company stuff is what it does
so no you're you're not bankrupt you
need to take the years to pay off the
debt as a matter of fact you need to
take months instead of years because you
get six jobs and um the person that you
become Warren while you fight your way
through this is much more important than
any mathematical equation that you're
looking at the toughness and the
perseverance that will be required of
you to work your way through this is
going to make you into the man that will
be able to build and manage wealth in
the next chapter of your life
but this is not a I'm just going to dust
this off get out free jail card kind not
it's not you know that's childish and no
you don't use bankruptcy that way and by
the way the way the bankruptcy laws are
written right now if you've got a big
income and this debts just an
inconvenience to you and you go in you
think you're going to file bankruptcy
and wipe out the stuff the the
bankruptcy laws are written now where
they're going to take you out of that
chapter 7 and put you in a Chapter 13
and make you pay payments a Chapter 13
is a payment bankruptcy lasts 5 years 60
months there are formulas that the law
has in place the regulations have in
place that force you to do that there's
mathematical tests and it forces you
into paying payments and so if you have
the ability to pay payments and just
don't want to um the law doesn't allow
you to do that anymore it's going to
smack you upside the head and make you
pay payments anyway in bankruptcy so
then you got double dump you got
payments and you got bankruptcy so you
got absolutely no traction you got none
of your little idea worked so no you're
not bankrupt yes you need to roll up
your sleeves and fight through this yes
you need to sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next yes you need to work
all the time yes you need to get the
scissors out and place them across the
credit cards and press hard repeatedly
it's called plastic surgery you need to
get out of the debt business you've got
to learn what caused you to get here and
then fight your way through it's what
happened to us afterwards afterwards we
had to start over we had to learn what
happened so that I'm never back there
again and I'm just going to start fresh
it's not going to work dude the law is
not going to let you and uh and you're
going to miss out on who Warren would
have become well yeah because you don't
change and that that's why we even are
cautious when people get a lump sum of
money whether from like an insurance
settlement or um you know um from uh
what is it when when someone passes an
estate no and insurance uh uh life
insurance insurance inheritance that's
what I was thinking of inheritance but
when people call and they have a sum of
money and they're like I can go and pay
off my debt we're like okay that's great
because yes we want you debt free and
you can use it but also you have to just
be careful in that when there's a sweep
of something that happens that comes
through again you're not changing who
you are and you're the one that got
yourself in this position and so the
beauty of the sacrifice through all of
that is you change with it so on the
other end you feel the pain that you've
walk through versus having one big sweep
that just kind of takes care of
everything so that's always even the
word of caution with yeah if you're
getting an insurance settlement or an
inheritance or something like that just
to be cautious that it's still you
handling that money and if you haven't
changed your money situation might not
change either yeah I'll go a step
further if you can pay your bills and
you just refuse to that's
stealing that's stealing it's unethical